and somebody started an argument online  recently I got an email about it about  you know if if drogon could beat Smaug  and you know as competitors I am and and  I would like my guys to win basically no  drug on drogon is a very young dragon  and still you know barely large enough  to get Danny into the sky you know  pretty formidable and small guys  gigantic not the mentioned affected  Smaug like talks and would probably have  an intellectual advantage there but  balerion could could give swag some  trouble they're they're they're more  equivalent to me in the size and  ferocity Department on the other day and  smoke would still have that talking  thing going but I don't know how much a  difference that takes makes that's a  question I hadn't thought